e aí
há 8 anos de idade com o sonho de ser
piloto no mundo em que cem porcento
somente esses são mulheres e menos ainda
mulheres africanas quem comanda sua vida
é hora de perceber o que está a
acontecer em sua vida não são por engano
as coisas que estão acontecer em sua
vida são uma série de escolhas suas
escolhas fizeram a 7 anos de idade o
nosso cérebro está em estado aos a
etiqueta que são ondas cerebrais
subconscientes isto é era aceita toda a
informação que recebe sem discriminar
sem avaliar e sem saber se a informação
recebida está errada ou certa mas é
claro uma criança ainda não tem a
capacidade
olá senhoras e senhores todos nós fomos
crianças e todos nós fomos influenciados
e condicionados de alguma forma
e hoje temos o poder de escolha que
coisa por poderosa as coisas
hoje eu vou contar uma história da
primeira vez que eu vi sobre a aviação
foi numa conversa entre meu irmão mais
velho o melhor amigo dele eles falavam
de aviões pilotos viagens entre outras
coisas então eu fiquei atento a essa
palavra de pilotagem depois de um tempo
é o filme pesquisar eu queria saber tudo
sobre a pilotagem piloto e aviões e lá
fui descobrir tudo que eu queria como
chegar até o meu sonho
eu pesquisei fiquei a saber que pilotos
são pessoas um bocado diferentes e que
eu tinha que ser uma pessoa para me
enquadrar nessa classe de pilotos
e quando terminei a escola secundária em
2008 não tinha os recursos para fazer a
pilotagem então os meus pais disseram
para mim olha filha tu não podes ficar
só tem que fazer alguma coisa então lá
pois me inscrevi no colégio para fazer
gestão de empresas só fiquei lá por dois
meses e desistir e disse para os meus
pais olha não é não é isso que eu quero
fazer mas depois de deixar o colégio
tinha que ter um plano meu plano era
procurar emprego guardar dinheiro e
quando reunir todos os recursos ir à
escola de pilotagem não foi bem assim
fiquei um ano inteiro tenho emprego mas
no ano a seguir consegui ter um emprego
numa empresa no aeroporto trabalhei lá
como a gente de terra
e depois de um tempo os meus os reuniram
algum dinheiro para começar com curso
comecei mas não era suficiente para
terminar
e lembro-me o primeiro dia que fui à
escola de pilotagem de 2 passos na
entrada e parei logo aquilo era um mar
de homens
o e logo a dúvida surgiu será que eu
posso será que eu vou conseguir no meio
de todas estas pessoas mas cá dentro de
mim eu disse sim senhora eu posso eu
merece e eu tenho a capacidade e fui em
frente e olha que a recepção foi
maravilhosa melhor do que eu esperava
então inscrevi-me estudei e quando os
recursos esgotaram vou vir para
moçambique a busca de uma bolsa e
felizmente consegui voltei para áfrica
do sul terminei o curso e em 2013
comecei a voar até hoje
bom obrigada
e aí
e no dia quatorze de dezembro de 2018
que é exatamente a um ano de hoje eu
comandei o primeiro voo totalmente
tripulado por mulheres e
eu cheguei aqui depois de alguns
comentários de alguns passageiros como é
uma mulher na frente será que vamos
chegar
ó e aqui estou eu aprendi que quando
tens um sonho
e tu e tens a coragem de ir atrás as
coisas que podes fazer um
ou seja a mudança que deseja ver no
mundo estas são as palavras sábias do
mahatma gandhi tiveram um grande impacto
na minha vida o meu desejo é de ver
pessoas que sonham e vão atrás dos seus
sonhos porque temos a capacidade e o
mundo onde as pessoas buscam o
autoconhecimento porque quando eu sei
quem eu sou melhor ser usar o meu ser
eu gostaria de partilhar três coisas que
ajudaram-me bastante na minha caminhada
aperta liderança é uma coisa que todos
nós sabemos às vezes não olhamos para
ela a devidamente perseverança te leva
do início até o fim quando tens desafios
no teu caminho to continue sempre em
frente porque é simplesmente uma lomba
na tua estrada
e a entrega o trabalho ou ideia quando
eu tenho uma ideia onde vejo eu tenho
que dar cem porcento de mim ou nada não
podes ir as metades porque ser as
metades de resultados e por último a
identidade própria é importante que eu
saiba quem eu sou quais são os mais
fortes e os fracos minhas habilidades
meus dons meus talentos para melhor
poder navegar nesta vida
e para fechar
eu digo na aviação sempre traçamos um
plano de voo de um ponto a para um ponto
b sempre sabemos de onde partimos onde
estamos e para onde vamos será que você
tem um plano de vida
hum será que tu sabes onde estás para
onde vais e ainda onde quer chegar quem
comanda sua vida a resposta a esta
pergunta deve ser um confiante e firme
eu eu tomando a minha vida obrigada a